moyennant que j'ai oublié dans le blues
way qui
ppda c'est peu dire ouais on s'est bien
l'avouer ouais non mais c'est vrai non
moi je prends pas position moi j'ai eu
dès qu'est ce que je peux te dire j'ai
eu très peu de contacts avec lui ouais
j'ai j'ai eu ma fille l'a fait
l'émission est venu faire léo ferré on a
pas mal de points communs ouais il a été
papa très tôt aux six mois et lui aussi
il avait 15 ans je crois et non à ben je
veux dire c'est quelqu'un de chez mr bah
on n'a pas parlé de pierre carles non
plus quelqu'un qui a été dit ray de tf1
parce qu'il a ouvert sa gueule ça arrive
aussi et le problème c'est que
maintenant pierre carles s'intéresse à
ppda ce tueur ah bon ouais tu vas voir
le magazine du port
c'était le 16 décembre dernier le
lendemain du retour de patrick poivre
d'arvor de cuba et en cet instant au
moment où il passe à l'écran la ppda
n'avait pas encore énoncé de contre
vérités au sujet de l'interview de fidel
castro donc il n'avait pas encore donné
dans l'intox mais écoutez bien ce qu'il
va dire fidel castro et 7 sortir de son
isolement économique mais n'est pas prêt
à aucun renoncement idéologique l'une
des équipes de tf1 l'a interrogé hier à
cuba intox voilà maintenant on peut dire
c'est de l'intox car voici à présent la
soi-disant interview de fidel castro par
l'équipe de tf1 telle qu'elle a été
diffusée dans le journal de 20h observez
bien attentivement ces images un jour
viendra où ce sera possible
le président jusqu alors la devise de
cuba c'était le socialisme ou la mort
est-ce que ça va pas devenir le
capitalisme ou la mort
en fait castro ne s'adresse pas là à
ppda et ppda ne lui a jamais posé cette
question c'est une supercherie et c'est
elle cette journaliste argentine qui a
en réalité posé la question à castro
comme on le voit dans la version
intégrale de la conférence de presse
filmée par la télévision cubaine et à
l'italie mort - de théo capital et
voilà filets 4 répond bien là la
question qui lui était posée mais
réécoutons le répondent à cette même
question sur tf1 puisque alors la devise
de cuba c'était le socialisme ou la mort
est-ce que ça va pas devenir le
capitalisme ou la mort
on doit
alors là vous l'avez entendu fidel
castro ne répond plus non le socialisme
ou la mort comme dans la version
originale et revoici la journaliste
argentine qui a posé la question à
castro
ppda est juste derrière elle au deuxième
plan à droite sur l'écran c'était donc
quelques minutes avant qu'il ne lui
subtilise sa question puis truc la
réponse de castro alors j'avais
interrogé il ya un peu plus d'un an ppda
au sujet de ces pratiques
journalistiques et notamment les
questions refaite après coup
alors là ça c'est un problème que j'ai
c'est de d'éviter je trouve ça très très
mauvais sont les questions qui sont
faites après parce que d'abord
elles peuvent être fausses mais je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec vous les
questions réécrites ou refaites c'est
pas bien non plus un peu une triche une
trique voilà c'est de la triche c'est
lui qu'il dise qu'il a fait avec fidel
castro on peut d'ailleurs sans revoir un
extrait qu'est ce que vous diriez à la
télévision française pour essayer de
défendre ce régime
qu'est ce que vous diriez à la
télévision française vous avez bien
entendu castro ne répond évidemment pas
à cette question dans la version
originale de la conférence de presse
puisqu'ils ne s'adressait pas à la
télévision française mais vous allez le
découvrir voilà c'est en réalité à cette
correspondante de radio argentine qu'il
répondait juste avant la base du métier
c'est de l'honnêteté on sait déjà c'est
pas l'objectivité c'est moi la netteté
lampre pda se trouvait en compagnie de
régis faucon à cuba filmé ici juste
avant la conférence de presse de castro
pas un cameraman d'une chaîne de
télévision hollandaise
vendeurs de saucisses iam selling
soit 7 juin en fait il n'est pas si loin
que ça de la vérité faucon a lui aussi
ceci sonne et les propos de castro
écoutez
est ce que voulait prouver pas un
formidable sentiment d'isolement
il faut résister
le magazine télérama qui a le premier
dévoilé la supercherie dans cet article
paru le 2 janvier dernier suite à quoi
ppda a envoyé un droit de réponse dans
lequel on peut lire notamment c'est
ainsi que nous avons pu approcher fidel
castro et lui poser au cours d'une
conférence de presse quelques questions
qui semblent l'avoir irrité c'est
complètement faux à la fin de la
conférence de presse ppda et son équipe
n'avait posé aucune question à fidel
castro claudia nice souvenez-vous se
trouvait justement ppda il faut qu'on
elle était dernièrement de passage à
paris
et voici la scène que vient de décrire
claudia fidel castro a fini de répondre
aux questions alors on ne verra pas sur
ces images l'équipe de tf1 mais on va
entendre la seule question qui est en
définitive poser à castro
pour la télé
mais castro est reparti à leur avoir
adressé la parole entouré de ses
conseillers de ses gardes du corps des
pda et régis faucon ensuite enregistrer
leurs vraies fausses questions faisant
comme si castro les écouter ils
n'écoutaient pas voilà la vérité
un truc comme ça je pense que ppda doit
réagir normalement et que il a déjà
réagi en écrivant à télérama le canard
enchaîné en a parlé et il est bien allé
an mal an mais les bienvenus ici pour
s'expliquer
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu